you know this video sponsored by
Squarespace make your next move
oh good yeah we'd be doubling down with
The Strange Case of stars and Jekyll and
mr. Hyde by robin lewis TV volume and
John Utterson swinging down the streets
of London what is coming he'll start
giving him the DL on a crazy ass story
brother like yo back in the women i peep
this shady cat named Hyde Street stop a
[ __ ] just cause she bump into him
soon as I saw that mess I told him he'd
best throw a c-note her away
I was me and his mob gonna turn this
into a scandal I like fun and obliged
brother but that check is signed by an
uptown gangster with solid rest what's
in still banking is hella strange right
so let us in recognize that the name on
a check of the clown of his man God the
jackal so I have two grubbing at the
crib Otteson check his files and learn
that this jackal cat is leaving all his
chatter - mr. Hyde mmm that don't sound
right
Utterson decided to drop in on one of
jackals [ __ ] voice dr. Lanyon but
language say he ain't seen dr. J's crazy
ass since they had a beef about his
bullsh t research like 10 years ago
August to start scoping out a spot that
had been seen it boy creeping up on the
house one night when hydros bond they
compensate for a sec before hot dusty -
laughs [ __ ] her chuckles man after
dinner partying Jekyll's honest and ask
him what the deal is with mr. Hyde but
dr. J just shakes that load off and say
don't trip on that baby nearly a year
later I doesn't get word that somebody
in town got ice so he pay a visit to the
police turns out mr. Hyde
then goes to one of his old crusty
clients Utterson leaves the fuzz The
Hives Trap House but do they know where
to be found
honestly hit up dr. J to get some
answers but Jekyll sale would that do no
more man be long gone
hands him a note from - he's sorry Paul
is [ __ ] thing is though both dr.
Jekyll and mr. Hyde got the same
handwriting hmm
what a mess too much God the dead back
to his regular self but that don't last
long so he don't let anyone come to his
crib no mo and next thing you know is
bro dr. lang and drops dead when he
leaves out us in a letter but he ain't
supposed to open it until something
wrong happens a Jekyll what gets real
with Jekyll's Butler tells Utterson that
dodgy they locked himself in that lab
for month and the boys on the other side
of that dope show is hella lame Jekyll's
maybe he's an Merc
so the two will break the door down if
I'm mr. Hyde did in Jekyll's clothes
from lips love it gu kills himself by
sipping on some poisoned juice Utterson
find an updated will a note telling him
to read lang is letter and a confession
from Hyde that's gonna explain
everything
Utterson heads home to relaying his
letter would say he started losing his
damn mind when he saw mr. Hart turning
to dr. Jekyll the shock aided his my to
eventually put him in the ground
the second letter saying how dr. J been
turning himself into a nappy monster now
bring out the dark side of his
personality that way he can do crazy
stunts a rig without no consequence
now Jekyll is having a good old time
morphing into that gnarly beast till he
started transforming in his sleep
knowing this [ __ ] is way too cray to
keep it alive but I'll kick the habit
for a while but when he started jonesing
for them dark deeds again he gave them
turned in the eyes and murk that old
geezer
after a wild Jekyll little so much
control that he start morphing in the
hide during the day so we hit up dr.
Langer for some Spirit to change him
back
sadly Jekyll just kept transforming
officially the brother couldn't find the
legit goods to make the amount of serum
to keep hide in check knowing that he
gonna be mr. Hyde forever soon he decide
to officer his Latta in by said he got a
new wheel leaving artisan all his
chatter so doesn't it ain't all bad
any literary og Italian Jekyll and Hyde
is a primo example of Gothic list it's
packing everything you'd expect nice
scenes city weather dishes death
transformations the creepy house with
story secrets and a freaky lab with more
dark corners than a porno theater
goddamn but the darkest thing going down
to this novella ain't even that it's
what Jesus is saying about human nature
see back in his day scientist thought
that one half of your brain reppin a
certain kind of personality and desire
another half rapping the exact opposite
righteous ball a Jekyll smart chill and
civilized cuz that's what doctors
thought the left side of the brain was
like whereas mr. Hyde is always coming
out hard gettin all savages [ __ ] cuz
homies thought the right half was more
primal and impulsive Stevenson slang and
images of animals to associate Hyde with
that beastly side this snappy scrub
growls like a dog and throws his limbs
around like a damn monkey her husband
ain't even that he looks like an animal
but this guy mr. Hyde soul is so evil
people just think he's a vane there is
something more if I could find a name
for God bless me the man seems hardly
human
something troglodytic shall we say or is
it the mere radiance of a foul soul that
thus transpires proof and transfigures
its clay continent I may be supposed to
represent down oh gee beasty that hater
snake from the Garden of Eden when he
moves back in the jackal in front of dr.
Lanyon he talks in history and even
tries to [ __ ] with laying his head by
pillar to his desire for dank ass
knowledge a new province of knowledge
and new avenues to fame and power shall
be laid open to you here in this room
upon the instant and your site should be
blasted by prodigy to stagger the
unbelief of seat man that boy might as
well be the double tempting Eve to grub
on that Apple from the tree of knowledge
but layin ain't only dude I see a little
hell and high-tensile talk about his
other half as that child of hill
and officer says he sees Satan's
signature in hard space damn eyes look
it's so janky it's like he straight up
Bible level even the real question we
all got to ask ourselves is are we all
on the same struggle as Paul dr. Jekyll
are we all one's rank away from becoming
monsters
maybe Stevens's Jam is a warning about
living in denial no one can keep that
dark side in further so you should be
true to yourself and recognize the good
and bad parts only big and a brother
truly find balance
you feel me yo thanks for checking out
side notes
peace y'all go thanks for kicking it
with me and if you're looking to build a
fly website to show off your skills
starting all our business I just share
your ideas and creations get on over to
squarespace.com last bundle where I say
to Jack easy-to-use tools to use quickly
and even we make the website you want
and they've got tons of a war when it's
my templates help you get started you
don't need to know coding or anything
and then giving all UL red ball is 10%
off your first order when you use the
offer code sign them
it's a didn't cut them up Squarespace
look ya'll up with a free 14-day trial
so you can see for yourself just how
easy it is so go to squarespace.com
slash signals or use the link in the
description below to sign up today and
you'll get a free 14 day trial to test
it out be sure to use the offer code
thug notes to get 10% off your order
thanks to Squarespace for being a homie
sponsoring this video and we've got lots
more videos on the way so go to our
channel page and if you have them
already make sure to subscribe while you
did catch y'all next time